welcome back dr nash is helping people
all across the valley lose weight
and she is changing lives it's a total
transformation which is fitting because
total transformation
is sponsoring the segment here's laura's
story
when i started with dr nash i weighed
over 300 pounds and i was pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds
and i no longer have that pre-diabetic
threat dr nash
it's more than just weight loss laura is
in her journey
incredible she lost over 135 pounds she
was pre-diabetic
you changed that tell us more about her
journey yeah laura lost a person like
it's
yes yeah and it is so much more than
weight loss so laura's 58 years old
laura firmly believed that
once she hit menopause she was screwed
she wasn't going to be able to lose the
weight
and the problem is while it was a
hormone problem it wasn't a menopause
problem
so when we adjusted the damage and
corrected it
not only did she lose weight she lost a
whole person and now she's keeping it
off which is what we want
absolutely and today i like this we're
going to share the top three questions
that you get asked by your clients i
have them right here
i'm going to ask you these questions you
give us the answer so the first one is
why can't most people lose weight and
their belly
and their thighs yeah so that's a great
question
belly and five fat usually indicate that
we have some kind of metabolic damage
that's
driving the weight gain in those areas
it can be hormones it can be
inflammation it can be fatty liver
means the body's fighting a problem
until the problem is corrected
the weight loss isn't going to follow it
what are the top three issues about
weight loss that your program solves
and i kind of alluded to that in the
last question right but that's okay
because i think you guys need to hear it
more than once
top three issues hormone damage dietary
hormone damage these are the things that
drive weight gain
high blood pressure diabetes and fatty
liver next one
inflammation that causes weight gain to
the belly because the body builds belly
fat to protect it
and then the last one fatty liver the
liver is the only organ that can turn
our fat into fuel so it needs to be
running right
how much weight can one expect to lose
with your progress
awesome my women typically lose between
13 and 30 pounds in just
a 30-day period my men are superstars
because they don't have hormones that
women do
so they lose anywhere from 22 to 35.
let's talk about your journey because
how many 12 years ago 80 pounds is your
journey
since 2009 yeah 12 years ago 80 pounds
holding strong helping others do the
same thing because we really don't want
to lose weight we want to
hold a normal weight there's a
difference to getting that goal
and that's that lose my like it's my
final question how many clients keep the
weight off and
what kind of calorie intake are we
talking per day
yeah so one of the worst things i can
think of is going on a diet only to diet
for the rest of your life so built into
my program we actually make your body
prove to you that you can hold the
weight loss
eating two to three thousand calories a
day including restaurant
fast food as long as you follow that
protocol you're golden
you still get to eat i love it dr nash
you always bring a special every week
what do you have for us
i do so normally that online evaluation
is 97
to talk to me and figure out what's
going on but if you mention that you saw
me talking to jc and only jc
then i'm going to be able to give you a
spot for 9.97 but i do only have 10 of
them
they go really fast so hit the website
and get your spot and let me
help you hold a normal way big thank you
to total transformation for sponsoring
this segment again visit drnash.com
eval for that special offer we will